we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail with a proposed topic of
discussion for the show let me let me
leave it at that
hey Davis I'd love it if you do a video
segment on the BDSM community and the
Fifty Shades of Grey books and movies
and remember community for over two
decades I'd be happy to discuss the
truth of and my experience with BDSM you
can contact me at nine seven eight also
for the record I have not had any
alcohol or cannabis prior to this
voicemail I think this topic is really
relevant as there are so many
preconceptions out there
thanks to these books and movies that
are simply not true
interesting so are you
is this a topic you're pining for
learning more about like are you
concerned Pat about all these false
understandings people have about BDSM I
mean a caller last week recommended that
we do a reoccurring mental health
segment yet I don't know if we can
really have the time to do a BDSM
segment to you know it's a lot to dig
into I guess but let me open it to the
audience if you are in agreement with
this caller that we really need to
dispel some false notions about the
world of BDSM then we can explore that
and I don't know if this is the right
person to address that issue I don't
know this person
BDSM credentials but it's something we
get absolutely looking I hope you don't
have to do too much investigative
research on this yeah this could be a
nice little job for you on on the
weekend you know on the bonus show today
Chelsea Manning is now free we will talk
about that astronomers have discovered a
puffy planet with the density of
styrofoam and as we mentioned earlier
Chris Cornell former singer from
Soundgarden and Audioslave has passed
away at age 52 we will address those
stories and more on today's bonus show
remember there is only one way to sign
up and get instant access to the bonus
show and that's by becoming a member at
david pakman.com forward slash
membership